le journal l'équipe l'excellent journal
l'équipe d'eire a publié une grande
enquête sur les salaires des
footballeurs en france et ça fait
énormément de bruit du coup on voulait
jouer avec vous il va falloir devinez
qui sont les cinq joueurs les mieux
payés et combien ils gagnent vous allez
voir c'est incroyable et surtout vous
allez voir qu'on retrouve pas mal le
même club forcément alors numéro 5
à votre avis numéro 5 cavani non ce
n'est pas un cavalier et c'est un joueur
du psg
c'est un très bon pote à moi parce que
et c'est à dire c'est une bonne question
que j'ai posée mais ce que ces salaires
joueurs aux salaires avec la pub est
tous dans salaires joue à quoi ça sert
joueurs entendus alors salaires joueur
qui est le numéro 5 de ligue 1 vous
allez voir que megan par mois s'est pas
embarrassé quand même très bons amis au
bar non légale a dit que je suis déjà
laignes de ces soirées partie non paul
valéry non non vous avez un très grand
joueur il est parti nous laisser
marquinho marquinhos un million deux
cent mille euros par mois pour
marquinhos et je lui fais un gros bisou
caisse fort à toi tu sais que je t'aime
et tu joues ailleurs que ces joggings
sont formidables c'est un marronnier 04
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure numéro 4
alan higginson cavani qui est très sympa
aussi qu à qui j'avais un gros bisou
edinson et un amour de may hamm edinson
cavani giuly c'est un garçon d'une
gentillesse incroyable de lille gagne un
million trois cent quarante cinq mille
euros par mois un million trois cent
quarante cinq mille euros par mois pour
cavani numéro trois c'est un défenseur
que je connais moins qui est très timide
et thiago silva ac thiago silva
exactement thiago silva léger moins un
million cinq cent mille euros par mois
thiago silva
voilà qui est petit minou et kaki
premier tient sur air défenseur
ah ouais y'a que des joueurs durant les
quinze premiers cépages numéro 2
à votre avis mba paix qu'il y avait ma
paie un million neuf cent dix mille
euros par mois ces numéros un bien bel
et bien sûr n'est pas avec 3 millions
d'euros par mois pour neymar 3 millions
d'euros par mois par mois alors qu'on
puisse comparer vous vous situez où je
me faire chier c'est qu'elle est choquée
pourtant ces salaires dit la vérité
raymond roger choquer ou pas choqué
c'est choquant en soi par rapport aux
gens mais ce sont des gens qui draine
des millions et aussi parce qu'il ya des
spectateurs qui viennent au stade qui
les regardent donc ce sont des marques à
eux seuls donc ça génère comme hollywood
voilà c'est comme du cinéma pour moi top
10 est occupé par des joueurs du paris
saint germain
le premier nom parisien est 12e c'est
l'attaquant de monaco
wissam ben yedder avec 650 mille euros
en moyenne petits pas choquer eric
naulleau non parce que ça fait partie
d'un système économique global on les
paye pour apporter encore plus voilà si
je demande aux téléspectateurs aussi ça
les salaires des footballeurs en
faudrait bien qu'on est là l'infographie
derrière olivier habite s'il pouvait se
réveiller oui non mais effectivement en
soi quand on entend que quelqu'un
qu'elle 3 millions d'euros par mois
on tombe de la chaise mais en même temps
j'imagine que les clubs qui le kilo qui
leur payent ça c'est pas mère teresa
donc s'ils le font c'est qui rapporte 10
fois plus donc voilà c'est l'économie de
marché ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
l'impôt est en france c'est ça moi je
fais choqué je pourrais pas souhaité pas
choquer les fans de foot mais je suis
fan de foot mais c'est pas pour ça que
je pas choqué c'est parce que l'impôt
est en france 6 50m bape est quant à
elle bat p honey marquant 3 millions
d'euros il ya sûrement un million cinq
qui sont pour les impôts
un million cinq c'est énorme surtout tu
n'allais pas sur ça que je suis pas
choqué parce que c'est de l'impôt bien
est-ce que tu choqué par sa badiane où
je suis partagé c'est à dire
qu'évidemment il génère de la richesse
il génère du spectacle et donc y crée
beaucoup d'emplois donc évidemment non
c'est comme les salaires d'aider des
grands patrons etc
d'un autre côté je peux comprendre dans
les inégalités qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui dans le climat actuel que
certains peuvent se dire
j'admire ces gens mais quelque part je
vois je joue je suis exclu de cette
richesse là je les appelle choquée moi
c'est même pas ça moi je me place sur le
plan de l'image me dis qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la tête d'un mec qui reçoit
sa part moi comment tu peux rester zen
comment tu vas grande à cassayet on nous
dit mais qui n en perd ses yeux on nous
dit les carrières sont courtes c'est pas
vrai ce qui gère bien les platines et où
il arrive à faire une vie entière dans
le domaine alors qu'est-ce que ça se
passe à quelqu'un qui s'y passera
peut-être c'est ce qui se passera mais
plus embêtant c'est un mec sait pas
comment gérer sur l'argent j'avais ma
famille je vais mettre ma casquette du
vieux con paris 3e et ac est voilà un
pays où un footballeur quelqu'un qui
tapent dans un ballon même si le feq
talent gagnent 500 mille fois plus par
mois qu'une infirmière qui soin des gens
au bon moment ça va craquer toutes les
révolutions naissent de ça c'est
indécent ils sont même obligés de se
cacher leurs richesses témoigne-t-on
gagne un moment c'est pas très bien sur
le tour ça pétera sait pas que
footballeur et trop payés chaque
infirmière est d'accord et ben si ça
rapporte gérard à diminuer le salaire
des footballeurs du paris saint germain
les infirmières alors moins payer les
coûts connexes communiquant je vais vous
dire le salaire moyen en ligue 1 il est
de 94 mille euros mensuels bruts
d'accord rien elle il faut savoir que le
plus petit salaire de ligue 1 à votre
avis c'est quoi plus petit salaire
le joueur qui gagnent les deux joueurs
qui gagnent le monde autour de 1000
euros par mois alors si jamais votre
avis combien il doit être à 7 notamment
vers la zone mais là dedans 2015 main
karl may 2009 20003 3500 le
contre-amiral retourner dans les six
mille 6000 outre ajuste la villa 5 buts
alors je vous dire le plus petit salaire
de ligue 1 c'est pour deux joueurs
d'angers gakpé et 3 hors et qu'ils
gagneraient apparemment 2800e roi un
bail au match ça et jouent parfois face
à neymar qui gagnent 3 millions d'euros
par mois c'est un coin
un très bel exemple ça c'est fou ça
c'est ce qu'il faut expliquer aux gens
quand on affiche des salaires comme ça
ils sont coise 30 40 50 peut-être 100
joueurs sur la planète a touché pas et
peut-être un million de joueurs qui
touchent moi ce qui est grave quand on
montre ça c'est tous les parents qui
poussent leurs enfants faire balout et
qui se prennent la tête il y en a même
qui prennent des crédits partant
cacahuètes pour que le petit il fasse
que du football
alors à cause de ses salaires là en 2016
le journal le parisien publié une
enquête complète sur les salaires versés
par le club du psg à ses joueurs et
entre les charges à 80 millions d'euros
et l'impôt à 90 millions d'euros
en une année faut savoir que paris saint
germain avait reversé 170 millions
d'euros dans les caisses de l'état passé
bon tuto en soit ça c'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vous dis ils doivent être
aux alentours de 250 300 millions
d'euros par an dans les caisses de
l'état